HE IS SAYING THAT HE IS FEELING
FINE.
KATIE, ALL OF THIS COMES AT A
TIME WHEN THE NATION’S NUMBERS
ARE SO HUGE.
YOU MENTIONED THE NEARLY 1900
TOTAL FOR JUST YESTERDAY OF
PEOPLE WHO PASSED AWAY.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
LOSING.
THIS FEELS LIKE IT DID ALMOST IN
THE BEGINNING.
IT FEELS LIKE WHAT THEY TOLD US
TO EXPECT.
YOU SEE GOVERNORS TALKING ABOUT
MASKS.
HERE IN NEW JERSEY THEY ARE.
THIS IS A SEPARATE CONVERSATION
TO PEOPLE THAN POLITICS.
YOU KNOW POLITICS INVADES
EVERYTHING.
>> YES.
THE VIRUS INVADES EVERYTHING.
EMILY, GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ARE
TRYING TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS
ABOUT LOCKDOWNS.
WE KNOW NOW A LOT MORE ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF LOCKDOWNS.
MISSED MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS AND
SUICIDE ARE UP, VETERAN SUICIDES
ARE UP WITH ISOLATION OF THIS
DISEASE.
WHERE ARE WE GOING BACK TO
LOCKDOWNS BALANCING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF KEEPING PEOPLE
FROM WORKING?
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
THAT’S WHY THIS IS SO HEART
BREAKING.
THERE IS A FAILURE IN MY OPINION
TO CAPTURE AND WEIGH IN AN EQUAL
MANNER ALL OF THE OTHER EFFECTS
HAPPENING THAT ARE HEART
BREAKING.
THE NOTION OF A SECOND ECONOMIC
LOCKDOWN IS FRANKLY TERRIFYING
TO ME.
JUST TO FOCUS ON ECONOMICS FOR
A QUICK MOMENT.
OVER 90% OF BUSINESSES IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE SMALL AND MEDIA
SIZED.
OVER 100,000 SHUTTERED
PERMANENTLY BECAUSE OF THE FIRST
COVID-19 LOCKDOWN AND 1 IN 5
BUSINESS OWNERS ESTIMATE THEY
WON’T MAKE IT TO THE END OF THE
YEAR.
THAT’S WITHOUT A SECOND
LOCKDOWN.
WE SPOKE IN THE LAST BLOCK ABOUT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THEY ARE AFFECTED AS ACTIVE
BLACK OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES
WERE DOWN 41% IN THE FIRST
LOCKDOWN.
THESE ARE REAL STATISTICS THAT
HAVE CONSEQUENCES FOR PEOPLE’S
LIVELIHOODS AND PUTTING FOOD ON
THE TABLE.
I SPEAK FOR MY OWN FAMILY.
WE LIVED PAYROLL TO PAYROLL WITH
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES.
THE OTHER ONES DIDN’T SURVIVE